wenn sie jetzt nur einen wunsch hatte
was würde sie sich wünschen
bis unmöglich ja gesundheit und heiko
gesundheit und ja okay und wenn man es
verhindern
seit die unmögliche der um mögliche
wunsch die realistische liebers was
könnte sie sich mal vorstellen was was
konnte mehrere in herzlija stefanie ist
freiwilliger sterbebegleiter eine
ständige konfrontation mit dem tod wie
geht er damit um wie versucht er den
patienten die angst vor ihrem sterben zu
nehmen
davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
wenn möglich die partie zur spürbaren
denn das dass ich den manchmal falsch
mit lux zu halten oder aber ich denke
die situation ist in der halter meistens
haben wir gemeinsam am bett sitzen und
da halt mal stellt sie immer seine dem
reeder und der mythische häufig schon
sehr cool vermietern das hospiz aargau
in druck unter dem dach befinden sich
neun zimmer für sterbende menschen
die motorik von familie ist durch einen
hirntumor eingeschränkt als
sterbebegleiter unterstützt stefan jacke
die patienten er ist einfach da manchmal
bis zum letzten atemzug mit aktiver
sterbehilfe begegnet us oder exit hat
das nichts zu tun
im hospiz und palliativ gepflegt margit
güntert leitet das hospiz von den
sterbebegleiter wünscht sie sich ein
gespür für die situation der patienten
[Musik]
der tod gehört dem hospiz zum alltag
für die patienten ist es das letzte
zimmer das letzte bett wenn es zu hause
oder im spital nicht mehr geht dann ist
das hospiz für die verbleibende zeit der
ort möglichst schmerzfreies sterben zu
können
durchschnittlich drei wochen sind die
patienten im hospiz bevor sie versterben
für die freiwilligen sterbebegleiter
bedeutet dass bereits nach kurzer zeit
wieder abschied zu nehmen
wer die begegnungen mit dem tod
aushalten will der sollte gefestigt sein
stephanie hat seine eigene persönliche
motivation um sich dieser aufgabe immer
wieder aufs neue zu stellen
ich denke wenn man realisiert hat wie
ihr gut drei jahren hätte geben wir das
sicher nicht immer spitz das ist
minute sondern dekoration betreuung von
der patienten in ihrer letzten
lebenszeit klar man wollte glauben
sprechen rolle spielen daher muss aber
immer vom patient ist ruhig wird sicher
missionieren im spiel bei den jack ist
daheim auf dem land im aargau der
pharmavertreter hat vier kinder
die familie ist die buch und heilig
gerade weil er viel unterwegs ist
braucht er diesen rückzugsort aber es
ist das hospiz welches ihm zuflucht vor
den kleinen banalitäten des
familienalltags bietet im gespräch mit
der familie haben sehr viel
oberflächlicher und los geht und wie
muss eine andere einspringen und so und
das ich dass ich toll aber es war
speziell durch sehr viel mehr
also sind die gespräche nehmen sich nur
an der oberfläche befinden sondern das
hat mir in der familie aber natürlich
nicht gewohnt und in dem haus spielt
sich das wird die vordergründig dass man
mit der patientin sehr dir für ungültig
sprecher fuhrmann fest in der familie
nicht in dem maß hält jeden tag und
dennis ist natürlich immer erst seit
kurzem kümmert sich stefan yaki um einen
patienten zudem einen besonders guten
draht hat grossenbacher ist 62 hat
akzeptiert dass der krebs 7 keine chance
lässt
seine frau ist immer bei ihm ein
abschied auf raten
aber wenn die zeit verrinnt dann ist
jede minute ein kostbares geschenk
stefan jacke ist einer der wenigen die
herr grossenbacher noch sehen möchte
inszenierte sie tat nichts für das die
das heim ihr jetzt durch die matte
stehen der direktor business macht
zuversicht wenn ihr physisch besucher
rede wo freunde bekannte verwandte was
auch himmel
regine nicht unbedingt zu gemüte
in welchem zustand der siegel wie und
was da passiert wenn sie jetzt 29 druck
könnte oder 940 löwen stunden beliefert
sie sagen da es wirklich jetzt mit der
erkenntnis und ich jetzt haben
angesprochen fühlt ein anderer richten
gegen im land würde sich dann ein bissle
bestimmt mit der situation ohne getriebe
da sie damals spitze
es stimmt würde vielleicht ja chronisch
krank ende holte was auch immer aber
grundsätzlich die grundzüge
der große wunsch dass er möglichst alles
worauf eine methodisch so gut dass nur
noch zu zweit machen das immer wieder
gold und das ist genau die schock
diagnose die schon froh dass sie
weiterhin eine firma für die beste die
hälfte also von - die schlechte die
hälfte geht für die genauso wie es hätte
nur meine schönste in diesen wochen
nämlich viele vorbereiten aber das
hätten meine schöne tage sagen ob das
weißt du von mir ist ja genau das
problem dass du die rasche sparkurse
niedriger als am tag
es ist spreche ich glaube das hilft das
so stefan jaxx eltern sind zu besuch
das zusammensein der familie ist nicht
selbstverständlich denn vor zehn jahren
klopfte das schicksal auch an stefans
tür aber die weiße herrscher ferrari in
der schule hat es auch offiziell
unterhält einmalertrag der andechser ja
sie will jetzt das höchste ob das stehen
ich habe den kunden die eigentlich gar
nicht aber ich möchte weg lebt und und
er hat es nicht so heike
lymphdrüsenkrebs und ich mir die
chemotherapie machen und der theke jahre
immer wieder gesund und so langsam dass
wir es jetzt eine und ich habe jetzt mal
zwölf ersichtlich der krebs ist
überstanden
aber wenn man im hospiz menschen sterben
sieht und selber den tod vor augen hatte
dann verliert die so vielleicht seinen
schrecken
ich würde nicht sagen dass sie weniger
angst hat oder wenn mir das weder höhere
drache dass sie denn irgendwie gelassen
und um wurde mit head mit amds darüber
dass sie natürlich eben noch jung damit
auch der 40 aber im hier ist wirklich zu
dir genau der umgang mit dem tod
verliert natürlich all ihren schrecken
wenn man so wie einige patienten
gestorben sind sowie positiver sieht und
erlebt also das ist mein erlösung ist
und das wäre ganz toll ich spreche meine
hand tolle einen umgang mit prozent der
800 patienten
er ist jetzt vorletzter gestorben ist
muss ich immer freute doch nicht so und
so und ich sehr oft mit dem tod und zeit
hat man es mir sagen wie wir
steht man denn wir machen das und der
salbe wenn ich an all das ist aber schon
der pixo und habe den handel ein
schlechter traum schnell und sie denkt
sie haben beide sehr kurz aber nicht
jeder lässt sich helfen und nicht immer
gelingt es stefan jacke das vertrauen
seiner patienten zu gewinnen war hubert
ist an krebs erkrankt sie hat zwei
kaputte ehen hinter sich keine kinder
und auch beruflich gab es enttäuschungen
sie ist davon überzeugt kein gutes leben
gehabt zu haben
ihre bitterkeit nährt die angst vor dem
was sie erwartet die jeder mensch starb
aber sie hat mich seit vor
was würde sich denn wünsche ja was er
vor allem schwarze machen ihnen am
stadtsee hatte ja danke da sind sie
natürlich immer noch spitze meiner guten
ort schmerzbekämpfung natürlich als
zentrales thema ich habe für uns und das
man innere der wirklich hart für das das
für sie ja und das ist doch immer sagen
der musik da wo mich seit mitte oktober
sie note und noch ein novum vor
ich hatte dort einfach kosten
[Musik]
zwei monate später kam punica oberli
sterben
anders hat sie gehofft hat wird es kein
leichter tut
stefan hackl möchte den kranken ihre
angst nehmen sie im wahrsten sinne des
wortes in ihrem sterben begleiten und
das bedeutet darüber aufzuklären wie es
denn sein könnte das sterben der seite
meint also friedlich eingeschlafen das
der moment vom vom stapel aus sehr
friedlich empfunden wird
angehörige oder von der lieth oder um
sind ich habe ja schon das erlaubt also
dass patienten sehr von ihrer angst
gleitet sind dass sie sicher wäre dass
sie gestikulieren und unter dir angst
ausdruck gaben dem sie einmal wirklich
fast schon fast stets meinem urlaub
ich habe die außen haben normal so wie
es ist wirklich so dass patienten im
laufe der zeit was ich bei euch sind mit
filmen abschließen felix sprecherin 4
und dass ihnen dank stimmt dass sie
wirklich friedlich einschlief
fertiggestellt
nicht allein und am liebsten in den
eigenen vier wänden
das ist die idealvorstellung vom sterben
die sterbebegleiter aus dem hospiz
aargau betreuen die patienten auf wunsch
auch zu hause stefan nutzt die
gelegenheit seiner kollegen über die
schulter zu schauen
porno ist nicht nur sterbebegleiterin
sondern auch eine bekannte der familie
zu besuch bei marianne schwager knecht
und ihrem an krebs erkrankten mann wert
drei tage vor seinem tod
marianne schwager knecht ist erschöpft
trotzdem hat sie sich gegen das hospiz
und für die pflege ihres mannes zu hause
entschieden
bis zur bestätigung gibt
sie machen auf mich einen sehr gefassten
sehr starken eindruck
also meine kommilitonen will ich das
eigentlich sehr gut denn gott mir das
gut aber nicht so konstant ist
ich bin fast wenige tage sind seit
unserem ersten treffen mit urin
grossenbacher und seiner frau vergangen
der krebspatient wird zunehmend
schwächer die pflegerin berichtet wie
seine nacht war
dann der große bach hätte ganze nacht
mit dem rücken zu mir
und die hat mit 41 frage will ich der
kleine schläft dann ist es ja schön
spritzig und weitere begegnungen mit
herrn grossenbacher sind wahrscheinlich
bald nicht mehr möglich allen ist klar
das wird wohl unser letzter besuch sein
das ehepaar grossenbacher interessiert
sich für die aufnahmen die beim ersten
treffen entstanden sind
das für die genauso wie meine schönste
es ist unser abschied von ueli
grossenbacher zwölf tage später schläft
er friedlich ein
[Musik]
eine gedenkfeier im hospiz einer der
einmal im jahr an alle verstorbenen das
wiedersehen mit sterbebegleiter mit
stefanie aki hat für die angehörigen
etwas tröstendes und sie kehren zurück
an den ort wo sie ihre liebsten
verabschieden konnten auch für den
sterbebegleiter selbst bietet das hospiz
vielleicht eines tages das letzte zimmer
und das letzte bett habe im hospiz ist
sicheren option und ich mir gut
vorstellen später mit hilfe im haus
spitz das mensch halt wirklich lieder
und dass sie schwer hand und dass sie
mühelos so dass es manchmal auf bundes-
mit schmerzen und adam hat ist schön im
hospiz starb aber selber muss jedes all
geschossen
macht ihr renten sie die begegnungen mit
menschen in ihrer letzten lebensphase
ein film über den tod aber vor allem ein
film über menschlichkeit mut und ein
sterben in würde